have you ever wondered what happened to
bail after Beauty and the Beast we get
to find out exactly how bail handles the
French Revolution in a new series of
novels from Disney keep watching to find
out the sad story of Belle's adventures
to Paris
[Music]
Disney has announced that they'll be
entering a new venture as of November
2020
the Queen's Counsel is a young adult
book series that follows the Disney
Princesses after their happily ever
afters witch princess is first it just
had to be the resident bookworm fell
from Beauty and the Beast your library
makes her small corner of the wall
she'll pick this first book is called
rebel rose here's what we know rebel
rose starts in the early days of the
French Revolution
Bella's visiting Paris from the excerpt
that Disney released we know that at the
very least
Lumiere has traveled with her Val sees
how poor and hungry many of the city's
peasants are she feels terrible for them
she also sees how the nobles are
treating them for the first time she
realizes that she is no longer seen as a
commoner that she spent her whole life
as one so she feels more connected to
them we also know that Val becomes a
hero for the people and they want her to
be the queen of all France who could
blame them she's kind smart and
understands what it's like to be one of
them the book also has quite a bit of
real history in it it will be exciting
to see how the world of Disney and the
real historical story collide here's
where we left Belle in the animated
movie she rescues her father then comes
back to the castle she tries to save the
beast from Gaston but fails she cries
and says she loves him that breaks the
spell and everyone turns back into a
human
the final scene is a ball after their
wedding the Beast or Prince Adam is now
a kind and benevolent Prince lot more
about Belle and the other characters in
the live-action film one of the most
important things we know is that Belle
was originally from Paris we get to see
where she lived when the Beast uses his
magic book to take them there they'll
finally learns what happened to her
mother and find out that her father fled
Paris so that they wouldn't get sick he
was an inventor and worked with the
Royals but he was a noble himself the
excerpt from rebel rose reveals that
Belle actually has the memories from her
childhood in Paris this is different
from the movie because she was just a
baby in the live-action movie The
Enchantress put a curse on the whole
village they didn't remember that they
lived near a castle some of them even
lost family members and friends who
worked in the castle they couldn't
remember them once the spell is broken
everyone reunites Belle and the prince
get married just like in the animated
version now she is a princess
we hope this means that everyone in the
village accepts her now why you spell
the perfect princess for the French
Revolution let's take a quick look at
what was going on in Paris and the rest
of France in the late 1700s
first of all France had a king the royal
family and all of the nobles were very
wealthy they were frivolous with their
money and wasted a lot of food they even
spent all of the country's money the
royal treasury was discovered to be
empty but millions of people were
starving
these regular people couldn't get any
help the nobles looked down at them and
the common people had no say in the
government where did all the money go
people wanted answers eventually they
got tired of all the inequality they
were going hungry while the royal family
threw huge parties people started
learning about the American Revolution
that had happened a few years before it
was successful and they stopped having a
king the commoners rose up together to
demand equality they took the royal
family prisoner this revolution is a
dark period in history the royal family
didn't survive and things didn't get
better some more powerful people took
control then a guy named Napoleon took
charge and became Emperor
des is grave your majesty people of
France are hungry rebel rose takes a
different approach to history it's
always fun to imagine what would have
happened if history had gone differently
the story starts in the early days of
the French Revolution all the people
really wanted was their leaders to
listen to them they wanted to stop being
hungry what if there had been a royal
who had listened to them imagine how
many lives would have been saved Belle
understands what it's like to be poor
she also understands what it's like to
have no control over her life she can
empathize with the people of France in
the book the people want her to become
Queen but first Belle has to learn to
believe in herself she doesn't really
feel like a royal yet she just happened
to be married to her prince and live in
a castle so why is Belle getting
involved in the French Revolution it
seems like Disney finally started
listening to their fans there are tons
of fan theories out there about Belle's
role in this famous error the costly
Center picture one of the most popular
theories doesn't involve changing
history at all the website Disney Theory
has a long post that connects Bell to
several other Disney movies the writer
thing said Belle and Prince Adam would
never have been involved in the
revolution see their village is pretty
far from Paris and most of the early
events happened there but it wasn't a
great time to be your royal Belle is one
smart lady and she wouldn't have stayed
around she wouldn't want to endanger her
friends or her father Belle and Adam
could have left France and fled to
safety we could definitely see this
happening they might have fled to
England or Germany the theory goes on to
connect frozen and Tarzan it suggests
that Belle and Adams descendants are the
Duke of weselton and Jane it actually
makes a lot of sense there's another
popular post that floats around the
internet it explains why Belle should
have married Gaston we know what you're
thinking Gaston is the worst but this
alternative universe is pretty valid
Gaston was a man of the people
the villagers loved him in the
live-action movie it's explained that he
is a veteran
he also supposedly saved the town from
Marauders as a teenager which is why the
town people adore him most of them
anyway once the French Revolution broke
out he would have been safe but felon
Adam wouldn't have been they would have
had to flee or else we know that the
series from Disney is taking a
completely different approach so what's
going to happen well let's take a look
at Belle's role and all of this she is
heartbroken by the poverty of the
commoners she can relate the excerpts
from Disney says that she remembers
being hungry as a child in Paris but now
she's a royal we imagine that she is
going to meet louis xvi and his wife
Marie Antoinette in fact since she is
now a princess she is probably sustained
at the palace inverse all during all of
this the Third Estate or the commoners
are starting to organize Belle sees
exactly how big of a problem this could
be she tries to convince the king and
queen to listen to the people but if the
story stays true to history the royal
family won't have enough money or
provisions to feed all of their people
so they'll have their hands tied but one
question remains why would the king and
queen listen to Belle in the first place
its frowned upon for commoners to marry
royalty we doubt that she is accepted at
the palace even though she is Adams wife
how will she saved the day well the tag
line of the book says that she needs to
become Queen there are a few ways this
could happen first of all the king and
queen could see eye-to-eye with Belle
they could decide to step down from
power so that they can save themselves
but this seems too easy and it's not
very likely another much darker Theory
sticks closer to the history of France
in real life commoners stormed the
palace of resolve this could happen in
the book as well without a royal family
felon Adam could be elected as the new
king and queen but this is still Disney
we're talking about so we don't think it
will be quite that dark it's probably
going to be somewhere in between
Belle is going to start helping the
Third Estate she will help them tone
down their actions she might think this
is the way to get the king to listen the
people are going to realize that she is
the best person to lead them and
hopefully history won't repeat itself
the king and queen will be sentenced to
some jail time for their crimes and
nothing more
who knows maybe they'll even be thrown
out of the castle and forced to live the
rest of their days as commoners Disney
also loves having its characters
discovers secrets about themselves we
don't know how closely the book will
stick to the movie canon we already know
that some things are different from the
live-action film since Bell now
remembers Paris what if Belle's father
has a huge secret about their past
she could be descended from royalty that
would give her a legitimate claim to the
throne there's also a chance the tagline
is a distractor she might decide that
being queen isn't the best option to
help france set up a successful
democracy how do you think Adam feels
during all of this we know he has
learned to be compassionate from Bell
and his time as a beast he used to be
just like the other Royals we really
hope that he is supportive a Belle as
she tries to save the people of France
but he might also be afraid of rocking
the boat we're sure that one way or
another he'll realize Belle is right by
the end of the book Belle also has to do
a lot of self-discovery she's spent her
whole life being an outsider now she has
to find confidence back in Paris I need
a girl like you who is so what do you
think will happen in rebel Rose let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
be our guest and click subscribe for
more fun content and be sure to give
this video a big thumbs up see you next
time
[Music]